listen I really want to start with a
sincere you are fantastic in this movie
I have nothing but positive things to
say I have to ask you that you've been
acting for a long time what has it been
like the last few years like especially
like something like this year you have
this film which you're incredible in you
have the color purple um you just did
sing sing I wrote down you have you just
worked with Ethan Cohen for driveway
dolls and you were the voice in
Transformers of Unicron which Al
incredible um what has it been like for
you these last few years and these roles
I think the beautiful thing is I I can
recognize the journey and like I'm a
journeyman I've been working for over 30
years and I started in the regional
theater um you know regional theaters
around the country you know and you know
just being a working actor you know
there's so many of us in that way so I
think I've honed my skills in that way
for so long then eventually to New York
and London and then making my my way in
film and television and now I'm um very
much a character actor and a leading man
at the same time it seems which is kind
of cool because I think the work that
I've been doing when I was out in the
regions was that work whether I was you
know playing a leading man at
Shakespeare production or I was playing
a clown so I have that facility and now
that I feel like that facility is being
really utilized in a really great way
which is awesome so I feel like I'm able
to play in different spaces and that
people are seeing my work and
appreciating it for what it is and again
it's just I've been working for a long
long time and so it's been a slow slow
um evolution in a way and now it seems
that uh a lot of people understand what
I've been doing or what I've been trying
to do which is really beautiful so it's
a great great time this role I'm sure
when you looked at the script and you
were offered the role and how you got
involved this must have been a a real
thrill for you to play this role but
also an incredible responsibility yeah
so can you talk a little bit about what
it was like for for you once you George
said hey it's you about getting ready to
step on set and then you get
terrified you get terrified because you
know you you feel like you may have uh
some of the tools that you may need to
um interrogate this role but then it's
also a sheer Terror because you feel a
an incredible responsibility for a story
like by rustin's that for years no one
would touch and he's someone who is who
the idea that he was the architect of
the march in Washington and he has
inspired Dr King and was one of Dr King
King's close friends and we don't know
much about him and so it felt like a
responsibility not only for many
communities for the lgbtqia communities
for uh civil rights communities for
people who knew and loved byard and
understood his impact in the world so it
felt like you know a lot of that went on
your shoulders and all I thought was let
me just do the work that's what by would
do every single they make himself useful
which is a line in the film he would
make him make myself useful every day to
just carve a little bit more of the work
and carve a little work and and not
think about not think about getting it
right but just trying to be as honest
and of service to the script and the
company that I was leading and being a
part of that was my North Star every
single day which day on the shoot on the
schedule did you have circled either
because you were incredibly excited to
film
or because you were scarless to step on
set that day there's a scene where
I I
uh I professed to Martin Luther King
towards the end uh about me being
homosexual and they want me to uh
possibly step away from the movement so
that the March can happen and he defends
himself for the first
time I worked on that scene for a very
long time because I wanted it to come
out in a very organic way and let it
build let the moment build and not think
too much about it to be honest and I
just wanted to come from this honest
place where it where
performer and
character do this so there's a little
bit of myself there's a little bit of
Bard there's a little bit of George
there's a little bit of every single
person in that company that we of that
130 people on that set that is in that
scene with me and I would look at my
cast most of the time and they will tell
you I would look at them before many
scenes because I need to take them
inside me on this journey because that's
what berer did he was a people person he
was you know um he inspired so many but
I wanted to take them all on a journey
with me and say this is all of our story
so that one in
particular was a moment that um I knew I
had to take a lot in and I knew that
that was the one that moment is for so
many people who maybe wish they had that
moment to to say this is Define who I am
in the world and challenge someone to
say Do you believe it or not his life
has so many amazing moments besides the
March on Washington if you could
actually make another movie of his
involving his life is what's the other
moment that you would love to see on
screen or be be depicted I feel like
when he was a teenager and he did his
first um protest which was like you know
protesting uh the food
in high school like you know that's kind
of dope he's like no this is garbage and
the year it's it's the year he was doing
this like 1946 or something like that
like it's you know what I mean yeah
exactly he's yeah for for a young uh
very much young queer black
Quaker boy to to say to stand up and say
no this isn't
right in his youth that is very
interesting to me I would love to see
that because I think that that's that's
very inspiring I think that'll Inspire
more youth to say Hey you have power
actually in your voice and if you're
committed to um what's right and that's
your North Star you can't go wrong last
thing for you what do you think it is
why is it taken so long for this story
to be told because it's such an integral
part of the March on Washington and the
things that he did are so incredible
well that's history for you isn't it
history will make um um shining examples
of some and on others they would push to
the Sou
um whether it's for the Optics of the
movement you name it but there comes a
time where you can't deny it anymore and
I think that these are these times now
where certain stories are coming to the
Forefront we can't deny it because also
I think you have people who want to make
sure that these stories are told you
know um President Barack Obama was very
much inspired by by Rustin he said the
reason why he became a community a
community um leader is because of a lot
of by's uh principles and teachings and
so he's an inspiration um he's inspired
so many and now people are saying oh
well we need to tell his story because
his story matters as well on that note I
want to say again how tremendous you are
in this role I wish you nothing but the
best thank you
man